JESSE WATTERS, AND GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
AFTER LOSING TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
IN 2016 AND FAILING TO BLOCK
BRETT KAVANAUGH'S CONFIRMATION,
DEMOCRATS ARE LOOKING TO CHANGE
THE RULES.
PROPOSALS WOULD ALTER THE
CONSTITUTION AND OFFEND HUNDREDS
OF YEARS OF PRECEDENT.
A GROWING NUMBER OF 2020
CANDIDATES ARE REVOLTING AGAINST
THE CURRENT MAKEUP OF THE
SUPREME COURT AND WANT MAJOR
CHANGES.
MORE ON THAT IN A MOMENT.
FIRST, ELIZABETH WARREN MAKING
THE IDEA OF ABOLISHING THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE PART OF HER
CAMPAIGN.
>> MY VIEW IS THAT EVERY VOTE
MATTERS.
THE WAY WE CAN MAKE THAT
HAPPEN...
[APPLAUSE]
IS THAT WE CAN HAVE NATIONAL
VOTING, AND THAT MEANS GET RID
OF THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT, I WAS HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS FOR
ABOUT A YEAR, JESSE, THAT THIS
IS COMING.
HILLARY CLINTON WHEN SHE LOST
HER DONALD TRUMP, SHE SAID WE
HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
NOW IT'S ALMOST BECOME A LITMUS
TEST AMONG DEMOCRATS THAT THEY
ARE ALL SAYING YEAH, I THINK WE
HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT THIS
ELECTORAL COLLEGE THING.
IT'S THE ONLY THING THEY THINK
THEY CAN WIN.
>> Jesse: THEY KNOW THAT THEY
CAN'T BEAT HIM UNDER THE RULES
SO THEY ARE TRYING TO RIG THE
SYSTEM.
IF I WERE A DEMOCRAT, I WOULD
SAY I CAN BEAT TRUMP WITH THE
RULES.
I WILL GET PAST 270.
I WILL RE-RACK THE MAP.
I WILL REBUILD THE BLUE WALL.
I THINK THAT LOOKS MUCH STRONGER
THAN THESE PEOPLE KNOW WHO LOOK
EXTREMELY WEAK.
RIGHT NOW I DON'T WANT THE
CITIES RUNNING THE COUNTRY.
SAN FRANCISCO IS ALMOST PARADIS
PARADISE.
L.A. IS NOT MUCH BETTER, AND
CHICAGO IS A CORRUPT SHOOTING
GALLERY.
LOOK AT WHAT NEW YORK DID
AMAZON.
I DON'T THINK WE NEED TO GIVE
THEM ANY MORE POWER THAN THEY
ALREADY HAVE.
THEY ARE TRYING TO
DISENFRANCHISE FLYOVER COUNTRY.
THEY ARE ONLY THEIR FOUR TIME OF
YEAR ANYWAY SO THEY DON'T WANT
TO HAVE THEM HAVE ANY MORE POWER
TO HAVE THEM HAVE ANY MORE POWE.
LIZ WARREN THINKS SHE KNOWS MORE
THAN FRANKLIN?
WE DESIGNED A CONSTITUTIONAL
REPUBLIC TO PREVENT MOB RULE.
THAT'S THE POINT.
WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO DO A
SHORT-CIRCUIT ALL OF THESE
SYSTEMS IN PLACE BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THEY CAN'T BEAT TRUMP.
THEY WANT TO LOWER THE VOTING
AGE TO 16.
THEY WANT TO IMPEACH.
THEY WANT TO STACK THE COURT.
THEY WANT TO KICK CONSERVATIVES
OFF TELEVISION.
ALL THE THINGS THEY ARE DOING
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEY CAN'T WIN
RIGHT NOW.
>> Dana: THE FOUNDING FATHERS,
THE CONSTITUTION.
>> Greg: YES, I READ OF THEM
AND HIGH SCHOOL.
>> Dana: IT'S CALLED THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
IF YOU GO TO A NATIONAL POPULAR
VOTE, IT WOULD BE THE UNITED
PEOPLE OF AMERICA, EXCEPT MAYBE
NOT SO UNITED.
>> Greg: TALK ABOUT VOTER
SUPPRESSION.
LIZ WARREN IS EITHER CHEATING TO
GET INTO COLLEGE OR CHEATING TO
GET OUT OF COLLEGE.
THANK YOU, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
THIS IS A CONTEST BETWEEN THE
CANDIDATES OF WHO CAN GO
FURTHER.
LET'S GET RID OF THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE.
LET'S MAKE THE SUPREME COURT
HAVE TERM LIMITS.
LET'S MAKE AN ELECTORAL COLLEGE
REPLACED WITH A POETRY SLAM
CONTEST AND THE LOSING SITE HAS
TO GIVE THEIR SALARIES TO
REPARATIONS.
THEY ARE DOING THIS, TO YOUR
POINT, IT'S HARD TO CHALLENGE
TRUMP ON HIS RECORD RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE THE ECONOMY IS BOOMING.
WHAT IS YOUR ALTERNATIVE?
NOT BOOMING?
THAT'S WHAT YOU'VE GOT.
SOME OF THESE GUYS AND GIRLS,
COMING UP WITH THE SO-CALLED
REVOLUTIONARY IDEAS, THEY ARE
THROWING STUFF UP THERE TO SEE
WHAT STICKS.
ODDLY ENOUGH, YOU'VE GOT TO
ADMIT TRUMP IS MORE LIKELY TO
COME UP WITH NEW IDEAS THAT HAVE
CHALLENGE THE REPUBLICAN
ORTHODOXY AND THE PARTIES
ORTHODOXY AND ANY IDEOLOGY'S
ORTHODOXY.
NORTH KOREA, TRADE, PRISON
REFORM, SYRIA.
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN CHASING
COLLUSION FOR TWO YEARS.
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE DEVOID OF
ANY KIND OF STRATEGY BECAUSE OF
-- THEY ARE SO LAZY.
THEY ARE HOPING FOR IMPEACHMENT
AND THEY'VE GOT NOTHING.
THEY SHOULD TRY TO CHALLENGE HIM
ON IDEAS.
THAT WOULD BE INTERESTING.
THE PROBLEM IS HIS IDEAS ARE
SOMETIMES SIMILAR TO THEIRS.
>> Dana: RIGHT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK, JUAN, TO
JESSE'S POINT, IF YOU ARE A
DEMOCRAT YOU ARE RUNNING, THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE IS NOT GOING
TO CHANGE FOR THE 2020 ELECTION.
MAYBE THEY WANT TO DO IT IN THE
FUTURE BUT SOMEBODY ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE SHOULD SAY I CAN
WIN IN THE CURRENT SYSTEM.
>> Juan: I THINK PEOPLE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
I DON'T ANYONE SAYING IT'S GOING
TO CHANGE FOR 2020.
>> Dana: I AM SAYING WHY WASTE
ALL THIS ENERGY?
>> Juan: IT'S A GOOD IDEA.
>> Dana: WHY?
>> Juan: WHEN YOU VOTE FOR
GOVERNOR, YOU VOTE ONE MAN, ONE
VOTE.
IN THE CURRENT ELECTORAL COLLEGE
SYSTEM, IT'S NOT ONE MAN, ONE
VOTE.
A VOTE FROM WYOMING IS WORTH
MORE THAN A VOTE COMING FROM
CALIFORNIA.
>> Dana: THAT'S NOT TRUE IN
THE HOUSE.
THAT'S WHY IT'S PROPORTIONAL IN
>> Juan: WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT THE HOUSE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
PRESIDENCY.
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE APPLIES
ONLY TO THE PRESIDENCY.
>> Dana: I KNOW.
>> Juan: IS NOT ABOUT
DEMOCRATS BEING SORE LOSERS.
IT'S ABOUT DEMOCRATS COMING UP
WITH IDEAS IN KEEPING WITH THE
FOUNDING FATHERS.
THE FOUNDING FATHERS ENGAGED --
IN THE FOUNDING FATHERS CREATED
A CONSTITUTION THIS ABLE TO
EVOLVE WITH A CHANGING NATION.
WHAT YOU GET IS THINGS LIKE
DOING AWAY WITH THE 3/5
COMPROMISE, SAYING WE MADE A
MISTAKE ABOUT THIS.
WE DID IT IN ORDER TO ESTABLISH
THE COUNTRY BECAUSE WE NEEDED
THE SLAVE STATES AND WE KNOW
IT'S WRONG SO WE UNDID IT.
>> Jesse: A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDED FOR ABOLISHING THE
COLLEGE?
>> Juan: HOW ABOUT WOMEN
VOTING?
THE CONSTITUTION DIDN'T ALLOW IT
WHEN IT WAS CREATED BUT IT DOES
NOW.
WHEN YOU PUT FORWARD IDEAS LIKE
THIS, IT'S HEALTHY.
IT SAYS JESSE AND JUAN SHOULD
HAVE A DEBATE.
NO ONE IS SAYING WE ARE GOING TO
BREAK THE RULES.
LET'S PUT FORWARD IDEAS THAT
MIGHT BE MORE REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE COUNTRY WE ARE TODAY.
>> Jesse: THEN THEY CAN HAVE A
DEBATE AND THEY CAN AMEND THE
CONSTITUTION BUT YOU KNOW THAT'S
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> Juan: THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE
PROPOSING.
>> Jesse: IT'S NEVER GOING TO
HAPPEN.
>> Dana: ELIZABETH WARREN MADE
THIS COMMENT IN MISSISSIPPI.
THERE ARE MORE VOTERS IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY THAN THERE ARE
IN ALL OF MISSISSIPPI.
IT'S A RACE AGAINST THE POPULAR
VOTE RATHER THAN THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE, WHY WOULD YOU CAMPAIGN
IN A SMALL STATE.
>> Emily: THE ARGUMENTS ARE
ANTITHETICAL TO THE WHOLE
APPROACH.
NO MATTER WHAT, THE COUNTER IS
THAT THE SAME THING IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
IT'S JUST THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO IGNORE THE FIRE
COUNTRY WHICH IS EXACTLY WHY
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS ELECTED
BECAUSE PEOPLE FELT IGNORED ON
POLICY.
NOW THEY'RE GOING TO BE IGNORED
WITH THE VOTE.
IT GOES AGAINST THE ARGUMENTS
FOR THE CITIZENSHIP QUESTION.
IF VOTE -- THERE'S THAT
HYPOCRISY ON SO MANY LEVELS.
THAT'S HOW IT GETS INTERPRETED
POORLY IN THAT WAY AND I THINK
IT ALSO WASTES EVERYONE'S TIME.
THERE IS A NATIONAL POPULAR VOTE
INTERSTATE COMPACT.
NONE OF IT IS GOING TO GET
ANYWHERE AND YET IT'S JUST
RHETORIC WASTING EVERYONE'S
TIME.
270s NOT GOING TO BE ACHIEVED
FOR THOSE STATES.
>> Dana: THERE WAS ANOTHER
TOPIC WE WANTED TO GET TO.
ELECTORAL COLLEGE IS ONE THING
THE DEMOCRATS ARE TALKING ABOUT
BUT ALSO 2020 CANDIDATES CALLING
FOR A MAJOR SHAKE-UP OF THE
SUPREME COURT.
>> WHAT IF THERE WERE FIVE
JUSTICES SELECTED BY DEMOCRATS
AND FIVE JUSTICES ELECTED BY
REPUBLICANS.
>> ONE IDEA THAT I THINK IS
INTERESTING AS YOU HAVE 15
MEMBERS BUT ONLY TANNER
APPOINTED IN THE POLITICAL
FASHION.
FIVE OF THEM CAN ONLY BE SEATED
BY A UNANIMOUS AGREEMENT OF THE
OTHER TEN.
>> I THINK THEY STOLE A
SUPREME COURT SEAT.
>> SHOULD WE KEEP IT NINE?
>> WE SHOULD HAVE A NATIONAL
CONVERSATION.
GIVE EVERY PRESIDENT THE ABILITY
TO CHOOSE THREE.
HOLDING ON THOSE SEATS IN WAYS I
DON'T LIKE IS HEALTHY.
>> Dana: PRESIDENT TRUMP
RESPONDING.
>> THE ONLY REASON IS THEY ARE
DOING THAT, THEY WANT TO TRY TO
CATCH UP.
IF THEY CAN'T CATCH UP THROUGH
THE VIOLENT BOX BY WINNING AN
ELECTION, THEY WANT TO TRY DOING
IT IN A DIFFERENT WAY.
WE HAVE NO INTEREST IN THAT
WHATSOEVER.
IT WON'T HAPPEN.
I GUARANTEE YOU IT WON'T HAPPEN
FOR SIX YEARS.
>> Dana: NO COURT PACKING.
>> Greg: IS IT A COINCIDENCE
THAT THEY LOSE BECAUSE OF THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE AND THEY WANT
TO CHANGE IT NOW THERE'S AN EDGE
FOR REPUBLICANS IN THE
SUPREME COURT SO THEY WANT TO
CHANGE THAT.
YOU CHANGE THE RULES, YOU CHANGE
THE RULES FOR EVERYBODY.
ASK HARRY REID HOW THAT WORKED
OUT.
IT'S SHORTSIGHTED TO DECIDE WHEN
YOU LOSE THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
THE RULES.
IF THE OTHER SIDE IS SMARTER
THAN YOU, THEY WILL JUST CATCH
UP.
>> Juan: THAT SOUNDS LIKE AN
ARGUMENT AGAINST A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY.
I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT IT UP.
THE BIGGER PROBLEM HERE IS
REPUBLICANS BROKE THE RULES IN
TERMS OF DENYING MERRICK GARLAND
A SUPREME COURT SEAT A YEAR INTO
A PROPERLY ELECTED, TWICE
ELECTED PRESIDENT, BARACK OBAMA.
THEY SAID WE'RE NOT GOING TO LET
YOU.
>> Jesse: YOU KNOW WHAT I
WOULD DO INSTEAD, I WOULD TRY
ADDING SEATS IN THE SENATE
INSTEAD OF ADDING SEATS TO THE
SUPREME COURT.
>> Dana: THE GUY ON MY SHOW
TODAY WANTED TO ABOLISH THE
SENATE TOO.
>> Jesse: CONSERVATIVES IN THE
EXIT POLLS, THEY SAID THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUE WITH IN 2016 WAS
THE SUPREME COURT.
IF DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO RUN ON
MESSING AROUND WITH THE
SUPREME COURT, GOING TO ACTIVATE
CONSERVATIVES SO MUCH IN 2020.
>> Juan: I THINK CHIEF JUSTICE
ROBERTS, WHO IS A REPUBLICAN,
CONCERNED ABOUT THE CREDIBILITY
OF THE COURT.
SEEN SIMPLY AS A RUBBER-STAMP
FOR WHOEVER HAS THE POLITICAL
MAJORITY.
>> Jesse: IF IT IS SO MUCH OF
A RUBBER-STAMP, WHY DO YOU WANT
TO WATER IT DOWN?
IF YOU TAKE THE SENATE AND YOU
TAKE THE WHITE HOUSE, THAT MEANS
THERE'S GOING TO BE A
WATERED-DOWN SUPREME COURT IT'S
BASICALLY GOING TO RUBBER-STAMP
SOCIALISM.
>> Juan: RESTORE THE
CREDIBILITY SO THAT YOU AND I --
>> Jesse: WHO ATTACKS THE
INTEGRITY OF THE COURT MORE?
>> Dana: IF IN HILLARY CLINTON
HAD WON AND SHE HAD PUT TWO
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES ON, I
DON'T THINK DEMOCRATS WOULD SAY
THE CREDIBILITY OF A COURT IS IN
QUESTION.
>> Emily: OF COURSE NOT.
WE WOULDN'T HAVE CANDIDATES
ANGER THERE IS A CRISIS ON THE
SUPREME COURT.
WE SAW THIS IN THE 30s.
IT'S WHAT ROOSEVELT WENT
THROUGH.
IT WAS A COMPLETE WASTE OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS AND IT
FRACTURED THE PARTY AND IT
DIDN'T WORK.
FOR 80 YEARS, THE JUSTICES WERE
MESSED AROUND WITH HIM THE
1800s AND THEN IT ENDED.
TERM LIMITS NEEDS A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT.
THESE JUDGES SERVE FOR GOOD
BEHAVIOR.
THEY CAN BE IMPEACHED AND THAT'S
IT.
I PERSONALLY WANT MY LAWMAKERS
TO FOCUS ON MAKING LAWS ARE NOT
MONKEYING AROUND WITH THE AMOUNT
OF SEATS THEY'RE GOING TO PUT ON
WHEN THAT'S NOT WHAT WE ARE HERE
TO DO AT ALL.
IT'S NOT GOING TO CHANGE
ANYTHING.
IF THERE IS SOME TYPE OF CRISIS
IN CONFIDENCE, THEN TO ME THAT
RHETORIC IS STIRRING THE POT
ANYWAY.
FOR EXAMPLE, TODAY THEY SAID IF
THE COURT AND INVENTED THE
INDIVIDUAL RIGHT TO BEAR ARMS,
THE COURT DIDN'T INVENT THAT.
IT'S IN THE CONSTITUTION.
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT, WE HAVE
LOTS OF ISSUES TO TALK ABOUT